Moving from interfaces into inheritance.
So a child class inherits all the variables, components, functions, events of the parent
class.
So a child class can override the settings and functions of the parent and change fundamental
behavior.
So a child class can also implement new functionality in addition to what inherits from a parent
class.
Let's think about a parent class as a vehicle.
So you've got a default template vehicle, it's just got a standard body shape, shall
we say.
It's got four wheels.
You want some kind of driving functionality and you've housed all the default basic functionality
of a vehicle and you can see that as a parent class.
What you can do from here is you can right click on that blueprint, create a child class
from that blueprint and then a new class will be created and it will house all of that
parent functionality.
But maybe now you want to add some car headlights or you want to create some additional behavior
for this child class that wasn't in the parent class.
So you can go ahead and do that.
But now what if you want some additional functionality to this child?
So you can create another child class of this child and maybe duplicate that three times
and maybe now child A still has the headlights and it still has all the parent functionality
but maybe you want to change the chassis now.
Maybe you want to change the type of vehicle it is by changing the static mesh.
You could change that on child A and it wouldn't change on child B.
So you can maybe think of a different car type or a different body type on child B
and it would still drive.
It would still have all this parent functionality.
It would still have its car headlights created in the child class but then you can then keep
adding customized functionality.
So whenever you find yourself creating maybe a type of interaction in a world or a certain
thing that you might be using multiple times but then changing small bits of functionality
on each one, it's a good practice to start thinking about housing something in a parent
class and then creating child classes from that so that you can work efficiently.
And also if a bug is in one for example, say you want to change the vehicle handling in
this example, you can change it in the parent class and then that change would still migrate
through to all the child classes as well.
So instead of maybe if you had ended up with four different car types, instead of going
in and changing each one four different times to fix this issue, you can just change it
in the parent class and then that updates for everything else as well.
So really powerful functionality.
And then Unreal also uses inheritance in almost all aspects of design.
So the actor class is a base class for all the objects that can be placed or spawned
in the level.
So lights, pawns, meshes are all child classes of the actor superclass.
So going back to our example of the object before in previous slides, objects is the
highest level in Unreal and then we go to actor and then say you're using point lights
in your Unreal Engine scene.
Well, a point light is inherited from a light class, which is inherited from an actor class,
which is inherited from the object class.
So you'll see this throughout Unreal.
You can keep moving up through the inherited classes if you need that intended functionality.
And then there's some additional resources on the documentation.
So if you just look for Blueprint visual scripting in Unreal Engine, you'll be able to find many
more resources there and these pages were put together by Sean.